[Applaudissements]
question que se pose jean michel maire
est ce qu'il vaut mieux manger avant
après ou pendant l'amour alors avancé si
on veut faire une performance toujours
pendant ces 1 positions du kama sutra
que je peux pas raconter ici et après
c'est pour se consoler de la contre
performance
ça vous va très bien jean michel cohen
également alors est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
faire une danse des sardines en mangeant
des macaronis ou faire une macarena en
mangeant des sardines alors non je vais
vous raconter une anecdote il ya la
salle de sport il donne un cours de
zumba à défi bien qu'il est super bien
taillés et à chaque fois qu'ils donnent
le cours de zumba ils s'arrêtent tous
les to les toutes les 5 minutes et ils
mangent une bouchée de sandwich au thon
donc conclusion la zumba îles sandwich
au thon ni la macarena ni arrêter ça et
le gall et super tie et quand elle est
bien là chaque fois et ensuite je pars
quoi r6 et ses voix les anecdotes ou les
a récupérés dans l'avenir des abeilles
borini boxe tu es un homme de défis
alors moi moi aussi je dois perdre du
poids il ya mai mais tous mes
petits-enfants qui se moque de moi
donc moi je vous propose un truc on se
donne un mois et dans un mois vous et
moi on perd 5 kg c'est dans le malheur a
donné 5 kg à 2 mais non
[Applaudissements]
plus de calories dans le croupion que
dans le reste du corps un pool homme je
peux me lâcher
oui normalement je devrais répondre le
corps d'une poule mais comme je sais pas
ce qui n'est dans le croupion
[Applaudissements]